hi my name is markiplier kindness hi my
name is markiplier no dude I couldn't
even do it smoothly okay that's the only
thing hi my name is markiplier and
currently that's not smooth if you want
to see exactly when and where we're
gonna be and see our amazing show that
we have in store for you just go to tore
down markiplier calm hi my name is Mark
Clark currently I'm not touring as my
friends in the earth we're going all
over the Europeans they exist I slide I
can't a kid not sloppy hi my name is
markiplier and we're currently on my
name is markiplier and I'm currently
touring in Europe right now with my
friends hi my name is markiplier and
currently on tour and all across Europe
with all of my friends if you want to
see one and where you can see us live
and in person in our highly rated and
highly recommended show just go Toor
dhall markiplier calm and see for
yourself it's full of fun it's full of
laughs and there's some emotional
moments too so check it out don't let
down and we'll see you in here